now let's get the latest forecast on
hurricane Harvey meteorologist Megan
Glaros of our Chicago station wbbm-tv is
here with that Megan good morning yes
good morning to you Anthony we do have
the absolute latest for you now the
system continues to weaken in terms of
its wind speed but not at all in terms
of what it's going to pump in here
moisture wise still tapping in to the
Gulf of Mexico still a category 1 storm
but now the winds on this are down to 80
miles per hour wind speeds at 80 the
forward motion still around the same at
about 6 miles per hour still just
crawling and that will not change over
the course of the next few days we
already have some high rainfall totals
courtesy of Harvey let's take a peek at
what's already on the map Victoria
already over 16 inches of rain McFadden
over 11 almost 12 inches of rain we're
at almost 11 and a half inches in
Australia a 9 inches Sugarland 9 inches
and it has only just began we're talking
about days of rainfall to come let's
take a look at what we're gonna deal
with here in terms of additional
rainfall coming in with us because again
remember even if it moves back out over
the Gulf Andrey strengthens we're still
pulling in that moisture if it stays
over the state of Texas still pulling in
that moisture we're looking at rainfall
totals that could include in this white
shaded area here upwards of three feet
of rain perhaps as much as 40 inches of
rainfall and I want to show you the
National Hurricane Center track because
if you've ever looked at a hurricane
before and you look at the track what we
often see is a cone and we call it the
cone of error this time around it does
this and so the cone is more like a
circle it's just going to sit and be
ander over portions of Texas tapping
into an unlimited source of moisture
we're talking about days on end of rain
here and again rainfall totals that
could top 40 inches in spots
Dayna meteorologist Megan Glaros of our
Chicago station WBBM thank you Megan